on va plus loin avec aujourd'hui annie
va journaliste indépendante bonjour anne
bonjour j appelle le titre de votre
dernier livre la france deux phases
votre rencontre avec des français à
l'occasion de cette campagne pour
l'élection présidentielle face à vous
gauthier rybinski la rédaction de france
24 aujourd'hui
la russie poursuit donc ses
bombardements tous azimuts en ukraine
elle les intensifie même si l'on en
croit le pentagone + 2 300 sorties
aériennes au cours des dernières 24
heures comme à kharkiv nicolaï vous-même
kiev désormais elle la capitale
ukrainienne où un centre commercial a
été littéralement pulvérisée comme à
marioupol surtout le port assiégé sur la
mer d'azov où l'union européenne dénonce
un crime de guerre majeure et coûter
trop cher et les la russie comme est
vraiment un pays de crimes de guerre
c'est le mot hawzi devons le prononcer
what's happening qui se passe à
marioupol est un crime de guerre massif
les bombes détruit ce tournoi tout le
monde l'est de manière aveugle et bordé
et narines des skins est une manne c'est
quelque chose d'horrible que nous devons
condamner dans l'est
de la ville sera complètement détruit et
les gens sont en train de mourir a
taillé plutôt que de calmer le jeu 1
pour montrer un profil ils ont plus
accepta moscou serait donc insensible au
concert de condamnations internationales
n'y va pas je crois que poutine a pas du
tout peur de devenir un paria ce qu'il
est ce qu'il est aujourd'hui et je crois
qu'il va même continuer jusqu'au moment
où il va penser qu'ils se retrouvent
dans une meilleure position diplomatique
il est en colère vis-à-vis des sanctions
parce que les sanctions que nous menons
contre lui il peut pas nous rendre la
pareille lui poutine il est toujours
c'est toujours un jeu de miroirs c'est à
dire ce que nous ce qu'ils nous fait
subir il prétend que c'est nous qui le
lui faisons subir on l'a vu avec ce
refus cette nuit de la capitulation de
l'offre de capitulation à l'udc
de l'ukraine mais évidemment que
l'ukraine allait pas capituler donc ça
il le savait il le fait exprès de dire
ce genre de chose pour que pour semer le
doute toujours la même chose donc il est
mécontent d'avoir failli au niveau
militaire et il est sans doute moins bon
tacticien que finalement ce qu'on
pensait qu'il était et son armée est
moins forte que ce qu'on pensait qu'elle
était effectivement la russie côté elle
continue de donner des justifications
malgré toi ces attaques le champ de
commercial par exemple aurait servi en
fait de dépôts d'armements et de
munitions tout comme d'ailleurs
précédemment l'hôpital ray servi à
abriter une unité dont vous nous aviez
parlé d'ailleurs un d'extrême droite
ukrainienne oui alors si on veut prendre
les choses avec un peu d'ironie si c'est
permis depuis le temps que l'armée russe
bombardent des dépôts de munitions deux
choses l'une soit l'armée ukrainienne en
a plus du tout soit elle en avait
tellement qu'elle aurait été capable de
plomber entièrement les 170 mille hommes
massés à la frontière ukrainienne depuis
le début c'est pas sérieux alors que ça
jette le doute pour nous qui regardons
c'est normal c'est bien il faut avoir un
doute raisonnable mais face à la lie à
ddd tonnes et des tonnes d'image face
aux centaines de bâtiments civils
bombardés d'hôpitaux de centres
commerciaux
un seul qui éventuellement ne serait pas
de ce serait un dépôt d'armes ukrainien
est ce que c'est ça qui doit nous faire
douter de la réalité globale de ce
conflit on peut encore une fois avoir
des doutes et les exprimer et dire oui
c'est vrai qu'à tel endroit leur vous
parlez de vous parler de ce centre
commercial que l'on voit à l'écran en ce
moment
apparemment peu de victimes ça ne serait
pas complètement farfelu de considérer
qu'un pays comme l'ukraine qui a une
culture de la résistance et de larmes
après tout l'union soviétique c'était
aussi un peuple qui était censé être en
armes
c'est un peu comme l'ex yougoslavie vous
trouviez effectivement des dépôts de
munitions d'armes un peu partout sur le
territoire oui peut-être et alors
pourquoi pas mais ça n'est pas une
manière une façon d'invalider ce qui se
passe dans l'ensemble du pays et pitt
malgré tout
et un centre commercial fut-il dépôt de
munitions en plein centre de la ville ça
a l'airé percée sur le site web comme
aux couches h aura quand même à
justifier malgré tout son intention fait
des efforts pour tenter de fournir des
explications oui parce que il faut
prouver aux yeux de poutine
l'explication première est liée
démentiel qui est celle de la
nazification ou de la dénazification de
l'ukraine c'est déraisonnable et c'est
surtout méconnaître complètement
l'histoire mais n'empêche que poutine
veut justifier son obsession et cette
lubie qui est effectivement l
déraisonnable commence un problème
romain pardon c'est que si poutine est
acculé et il est de plus en plus c'est
dangereux pour nous tous donc il va
quand même bien falloir trouver une
solution pour qu'il se sente moins
acculé pour qu'on commence à négocier
véritablement mais comment cette
propagande est elle perçue par les
russes eux-mêmes ils adhèrent au
narratif du kremlin ça c'est la grande
question
il n'adhère pas tous bien sûr que non on
l'a vu on l'a vu dès le début de cette
opération militaire on a vu des
individus très courageux qui sortait
dans la rue avec cette pancarte non à la
guerre on a vu cette journaliste sur la
première chaîne qui a profité du journal
télévisé pour avoir elle aussi une
pancarte il ya tous les jours des gens
qui manifestent leur leur horreur leur
honte et ils partent ils ont parce que
ils eux aussi ils ont quitté en masse la
russie il y à peu près 250 milles russes
qui ont quitté la russie depuis le début
des opérations où sont ils partis ils
sont partis généralement assez proche de
la russie en géorgie la capitale
tbilissi où ailleurs evans en arménie
parce que là ils n'ont pas besoin de
visa et ils peuvent le cas échéant
revenir
et c'est pas les oligarques dans se
parle c'est pas ce dont on est en train
de de geler les avoirs les yachts etc
etc mais donc et il ya ceux qui restent
ceux qui restent je les regarde à la sur
les chaînes youtube puisque facebook est
interdit instagram est interdite tik tok
est interdite il reste whatsapp et il
reste les chaînes youtube même s'il est
vrai c'est possible que ça que ça soit
fermé assez vite c'est youtube met donc
il y a c'est niet sobczak est une
journaliste d'une ancienne chaîne et
donc d'ailleurs de 0,24 à moscou oui oui
toutes ses nuances belgique
le documentaire sur wagner mais c'est
une journaliste effectivement le nom est
très proche de chiasso tchèque et la
fille d'anatolie sobczak oui exactement
meilleure façon de poutine c'est ça et
qui est décédé et sa mère et sénatrices
la maire d'auxerre sobczak et je l'avais
dit ici évidente avec son costume elle
avait non mais sa mère avait récemment
condamnée en tant que sénatrice quand
même c'est aussi un acte courageux
condamné cette guerre mais ksenia
sobczak donc elle continue à faire du
journalisme sur youtube et là il parlait
récemment justement de ce qui reste des
blogueurs
des actrices des acteurs des gens du
show-biz qui ont décidé de rester et qui
se pose tous des questions qui sont dans
un désarroi total et qui se disent
finalement qui essaie de comprendre le
nouveau monde dans lequel ils vont
devoir vivre vivre ce nouveau monde de
la censure tout le monde parle d'un
retour à l'ex urss voire pire et il faut
dire que le fait qu'il n'y ait eu aucun
mort dans le théâtre bombardé où d'après
kiev 600 à 800 civils avaient trouvé
refuge le le faible nombre de victimes
aussi dans la maternité bombardé
toujours à marioupol tout ça peut
alimenter les discours complotistes
forcément puisque on nous en parlons et
encore une fois il faut avoir ce il faut
avoir ce doute il faut jamais avoir non
plus hors de raison le fait que ces
interrogations aussi légitime soit elle
sert aussi l'agresseur de sorte que une
fois que vous aurez un doute et c'est là
la difficulté vous aurez un doute sur un
cas vous parliez de la maternité de
marioupol
souvenez de ce qu'on a dit on a dit
qu'une une jeune femme qui était
enceinte et en donnait son emploi
précédent elle était dans l'industrie la
cosmétique était forcément quelqu'un qui
avait finalement me falsifié la
situation et qu'elle aurait été qu'elle
se serait elle-même maquiller pourra
vous donner l'impression qu'elle avait
du sang sur le fond etc etc
il faut effectivement aller au fond cet
événement mais toujours en gardant à
l'esprit que quand on va prendre un
exemple et puis parce que nous ne voyons
pas tout mais nous sommes susceptibles
de relayer l'entreprise de propagande
qui dit c'est partout comme ça parce que
c'est ça l'idée c'est pas un exemple
effectivement il peut y avoir marioupol
nous n'en savons pas plus aujourd'hui
même si il ya eu des camps même des
enquêtes assez concluantes notamment sur
la le diamètre des impacts figurant dans
les immeubles et correspondant à ceux
des obus prusse mais s'il y a un doute
encore une fois il faut le remettre dans
tout ce contexte et je ne peux que vous
répétez ce que je disais tout à l'heure
l'ensemble des frappes et des
destructions vous prenez mikko live par
exemple sans parler de marioupol ce sont
des choses qui sont manifestement
destinée à effrayer les civils et à les
tuer à des endroits où il n'ya pas de
dépôt d'armes de munitions mais enfin ça
gauthier ça s'appelle la guerre tout
simplement c'est ça la guerre
aujourd'hui oui ça a toujours été ça oui
c'est de la manipulation c'est de
l'instrumentalisation et personne ne
comprend rien sauf ceux qui sont sur le
terrain et encore parce que quand on est
sur le terrain on est à un seul endroit
du terrain et on n'a jamais une vision
globale oui donc c'est la guerre sauf
que la grande différence aujourd'hui
c'est qu'elle se passe en direct que
nous avons pas trop de sources
d'informations justes justement se
demande si ce sont des vraiment
informations des vrais deux formations
ne suis pas d'accord avec vous parce
qu'on a ri on est dans la confusion la
plus tôt de oui on peut être dans la
confusion à condition qu'on ait aucun e
repères intellectuels sur la question
quand on a un agresseur qui s'expriment
comme tel qui parle de dé nazifié et
c'est ça bien sûr non mais attendez il
faut le suivre justement à la lettre il
faut prendre pour ce qu'est une
agression qui est de type très largement
idéologique c'est ce qu'on vient de
découvrir c'est le retour des affects de
poutine le retour mais moi je parle du
grand public de ce précisément grand
précisé mais dans la confusion non le
camp la confusion quand ils regardent
des chaînes comme france 24
c'est à dire des gens qui font bien leur
boulot sérieusement non mais qu'il ya un
agresseur il ya un agressé mais la
guerre c'est fait pour faire peur et
donc c'est évidemment si vous laissez
les images effectivement comme vous
dites on est dans la confusion oui c'est
à dire qu'il faudrait expliquer les
décrypter bien sur un ton résolument et
vous le faites très bien le jeu en
russie elle interdit facebook instagram
pour cause d'activité extremis dernière
restriction date pour des russes déjà
soumis au régime de sanctions le plus
sévère qu'ils aient jamais connues
comment réagissent et russe à ces
sanctions on y va comment expliquer leur
relative placidité vu de l'extérieur non
on peut pas dire de la placidité mais
d'abord on peut pas dire les russes ce
peuple tel un seul homme ne peut pas
tout d'un coup parce que leur leader a
envahi un autre pays se retourner contre
lui ils sont démunis ils sont absolument
unis ils font comme ils peuvent c'est à
dire je l'expliquais tout à l'heure
individuellement certains osent certains
actes d'autres n'osent pas mais n'en
pense pas moins et puis il ya ceux aussi
on les voit aussi malheureusement qui
vont suivre avec poutine je crois que
c'était ce samedi au stade loujniki qui
est un des plus grands stades de moscou
il y avait une retransmission en direct
de évidemment de ce que disait poutine
et il y avait une journaliste de novaïa
gazeta qui était sur la chaîne youtube
du journal puisque le journal évidemment
ne peut plus parler et qui explique
qu'ils posaient la question simplement
aux gens pourquoi vous êtes venus les
figures fermer des rues si à ce qu'il
disait mais vous vous travaillez pour
qui ce que de la dépend des leurs
réponses ou alors ceux qui disaient mais
moi je ne veux pas répondre je ne peux
pas répondre comprenne qui pourra y en a
même un qui lui a écrit quelque chose
sur son portable donc voilà les russes
sont dans un moment de panique absolue
également pour eux leur pays se ferme on
ne sait pas on ne sait pas quelles sont
les le nombre de morts russe on n'a eu
qu'un seul chiffre il ya une semaine
reconnue par les autorités russes par le
kremlin qui était de 500 hommes les
ukrainiens nous disent qu'on est à plus
de 15 villes pour les russes ils ont
l'avancé 3000 déjà au bout de deux honda
de toute façon il y en a énormément il y
en a énormément il y en aura de plus en
plus si la guerre est longue et je ne
parle même pas du drame absolu si
finalement kiev si les russes finissent
par prendre kiev ou pas vraiment vouloir
part avancé pour vouloir le prendre ras
des pertes des deux côtés donc
évidemment le peuple russe qui n'est pas
au courant de tout ça qui n'arrive qui
n'a pas les mêmes images que nous ne
peut pas réagir de ré façon que nous ce
n'est pas possible en tout cas pas pour
le moment mais l'histoire mondiale c'est
l'histoire l'histoire de l'humanité
c'est l'histoire de trahison donc un
jour il y aura quelqu'un qui travaillera
dans l'entourage de poutine ad on n'en
est pas là adhésion pour l'heure à
vladimir poutine gauthier le patriotisme
chez les russes l'emportent sur le
matérialisme combien crainte de la
répression les deux comme vient de le
dire très justement and le patriotisme
qui l'emportent sur le matériel ça ne
date pas d'hier quand vous regardez les
20 précédents dernières années
c'est-à-dire depuis en gros que vladimir
poutine est au pouvoir
continuellement dans des études qui
était encore à l'époque assez fiable
vous constatez que des personnes qui
n'ont par exemple pas vu mais un
centimètre un millimètre de différences
dans leur sort avec poutine donc ils
sont globalement peut-être des perdants
de leur côté nyan pas malgré tout ils
continuent à voter pour lui ça veut dire
aussi c'est pour ça que je disais que
c'était le retour delà de l'idéologie de
la politique ça veut dire aussi que la
nourriture symbolique cavale certains
russes est presque aussi importante
parfois que les nourritures terrestres
ça veut dire ça ça veut dire qu'on est
au pouvoir ni brillé au nationalisme et
ça ne serait pas la première fois
malheureusement on a d'autres exemples
dans le passé ou ou 7,7 cette tension là
cette teneur la serre fait office et
remplace le matériel le le quotidien
nécessaire un mot simplement les russes
n'oublierons jamais qui se sont mis à
mieux vivre sous poutine fait grâce à
l'ère poutine dans la classe moyenne
russie l'émergence de la classe moyenne
russe c'est pendant le début les dix
quinze premières années du règne poutine
donc peut-être lui pardonne t-il entre
guillemets ce qu'il est en train de
faire aujourd'hui parce qu'ils ont mieux
vécu grâce à à cela est évidemment les
russes compare avec ce qui est leur
propre histoire qui n'est pas la nôtre
je vous le rappelle dans ce cas où une
surprise pour sa gellar offs éclaire
emmanuel macron sort du lot à ses yeux
malgré la détermination française à
appliquer ces sanctions contre la russie
c'est le seul leader européen pour
sergey lavrov à ne pas se coucher devant
les états unis il l'a dit lors d'un
entretien qu'est ce qui a bien pu
conduire saga lavrov à de telles paroles
gauthier c'est d'autant plus j toulouse
je crois que trois 3 semaines auparavant
lavrov avait dit de macron qu'il était
en gros un petit coq et qui lorsqu'il
avait parlé de la syrie avait une
attitude néocolonialistes donc c'était
ça un peu le bon alors est-ce qu'il ya
quelque chose de nouveau est ce que ça
veut dire que par exemple la russie
considère qu'au sein des européens la
france militairement est le pays le plus
aimé enfin plus qu émergent affirmé est
ce que à partir de là il ya quelque
chose en décider est-ce que c'est aussi
une manière d'enfoncer un coin on le
voit bien ses deux qui consisterait à
dire aux français bon vous vous êtes des
vrais européens les etats-unis se
fichent de vous on va essayer de
s'entendre entre nous le laisse la
parole à halle pour m pour conclure je
pense que c'est très étonnant
effectivement que lavrov est nommé
emmanuel macron et de façon positive
mais est-ce que ça serait pas plutôt
dans le but de
fissurer plutôt le bloc occidental un
agacer les états unis c'est peut-être ça
qui était la volonté induite de lavrov
qui est pas connue pour ce genre de
propos merci niva d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui et merci à gauthier rybinski
d'être resté avec nous puisque gauthier
n'était pas prévu sur cette soirée il a
remplacé au pied levé ma consoeur n'a
pas pu venir et donc merci voir à
gauthier d'être resté avec nous on se
retrouve dans quatre minutes pour un
nouveau journal dans prayols
[Musique]